hello everybody John Luke here I'm
joined by Alessandro hello and all the
sound true you got to play three hours
of Star Wars Jedi fall in order that's
right all right yeah so this is the
final preview event of the game before
it comes out next month our last chance
to look at it so I guess as somebody who
saw that III event and then where they
kind of showed off the game for the
first time but really hasn't paid too
much attention since I guess I want to
know like what is the structure of this
game what do you do in this game so
basically this is the first real Star
Wars Metroidvania game and it's very
much in the vein of like I guess do you
use a comparison to the recent God of
War like own that's sort of like
singular like an enclosed environment
where you that gradually expands okay
after you acquire more abilities but
also it includes elements of uncharted
and of course the soul series which was
very much talked about following the e3
presentation right right so III
presentation was kind of just showing
off the combat and it sort of had you
know yeah like you said that kind of sec
euro dark souls kind of feel I guess we
can talk about that for a second how did
that feel having played it yourself it
felt very much in the vein of Secura
actually like you know you you you're
very agile you can jump and you can
dodge and of course you can parry
strikes um you can actually parry as
you've seen in the trailers of course
like the laser shots from stormtroopers
I was doing that very easily and there
was actually some stormtroopers in the
distance who were you know firing off
shots and uh as soon as they fired one
off I just easily deflected it and you
know it just immediately went back and
killed him instantly so it was very
satisfying did it did it feel demanding
and all the way the souls games have
kind of always felt actually no I mean
it's very it's a very accessible like a
tough on the souls like that's familiar
Souls design I felt it was very sort of
relaxed as well like I'm I can still
feel that sort of like tension during
fights but I can I can say that it's
very forgiving so like you know if for
instance like if you fall down like a
pit you'll actually just come back to
you know the service with just some help
long okay it's not instant death right
but there is like a very sort of
interesting death like mechanic that's
very similar to the soul series so no
okay actually if you die then the enemy
that killed you
basically steals all of your current
experience okay yeah and they'll
actually take off a sliver of your
health as well in your force meter so to
get that back you actually have to go
and find that and in particular enemy
okay yeah that is like straight out of
like no porn and yeah interesting
interesting
so there's the combat like you so
there's the platform is there anything
interesting with the platform you kind
of said it's just uncharted it's very
much in the vein of Uncharted it but I
did sort of recall some I guess some
familiar elements to Prince of Persia at
the sands of time where you can actually
sort of chain together different sort of
platforming like styles like you know
you slide but then you jump they not so
it was very is very fluid and you know
but I feel like the the key pillar of
this game is very much the combat and
you know sort of the exploration okay so
the platforming is more there to get you
from one place to another it's not
necessarily a challenge and itself
necessarily um there are some puzzles
definitely where you have to use your
your force powers to actually sort of
many manipulative certain platforms and
sort of clear those sort of debris but
again it didn't feel super sophisticated
in this in the way that uh combat does
right okay so we had the platforming we
have the combat and then you said it's
all kind of tied together through this
Metroidvania how did that feel compared
to I guess sort of like what we what we
think of as like a Metroidvania honestly
the best way like I would describe it
was that it's very similar to like you
know maybe a Metroid Prime you know and
it actually has that very familiar sort
of 3d map where you can you pull a
happen you can sort of move it around
and uh you know and of course
Metroidvania is very much about
exploring like you know very enclosed
environments where that gradually expand
once you get more powers and you know
that that was definitely there and like
you know actually after acquiring the
force push ability I was able to sort of
like clear pathways to different areas
of the the particular planet we were on
which was on the planet zepho which is a
new planet you know that's exclusive to
this game so do you feel like the game
was encouraging you to figure things out
where to go next did you ever feel like
lost or felt like you you've had options
and where to go I felt like it was
pretty clear and where to go for the
most part but there are still some
elements of the environment that I felt
like was a bit vague you
is very much a golden path to follow
like for the story like you know so but
there's always like you know sort of
like different tangents and the pathways
that you can sort of follow to lead to
the secrets so you do have like an
objective that's kind of leading you
down a path so it's not quite Super
Metroid levels of go go at it like
there's a little bit of direction there
there's a bit of direction but you know
there's still a lot of areas to sort of
like find off the beaten path you said
that the planning run was a new planet
they showed there are multiple planets
in this game yes when we started we
actually had the selection of either two
planets one was zepho and the other was
a darth amir d'Arthur mayor being a sort
of returning planet from the Clone Wars
series um yeah that's uh Darth Maul I
think he's like species related to that
plane I believe so but um actually the
the plan is sort of unofficially named
the rancor planet no the rancor is being
nice or those massive beasts from a
return of the rancor yeah yeah so I
actually went there and when you're
going there you're actually your allies
on the ship CIRA and Brees will actually
warn you like you know are you sure you
want to do that it's very difficult it
but you're free to go there if you want
and try it but so there is that level of
you can you can kind of pick where you
want to go oh absolutely
and it's a very very difficult planet
and is like within five minutes I was
like I do not belong here yeah one of
the reasons for that is because you know
it's not nothing to do with like sort of
like character levels or anything like
that because that's not in the game
there's nothing like that in the game
this is an RPG this is very much action
driven and write a lot of the enemies
there you know had very sort of
sophisticated attack patterns and I just
couldn't keep up with them so
interesting so yeah maybe like when you
replay the game you could potentially
just be skilled enough at the way the
game works that you could you could do
that right up front that's interesting
yeah and of course when you go back like
you know maybe towards like you know
maybe the midpoint or towards the end of
the game you know you'll be you'll be
able to sort of like stand up to the
enemies they're a lot easier because
you'll have like you know you'll
increase the powers of Cal Cal the main
character and his force abilities and
you know you'll have an easier time for
deflecting attacks and no dodging no it
was very interesting just just how they
offered us the choice to go there if we
want and uh right it is actually
possible to sort of clear through a
pretty significant chunk
of that that planet from that point at
the beginning of the game so hmm so I'm
very curious to see if like any players
will be able to sort of uh no no track
clear clear out most of it like on their
own like you know just bare bones like
yeah so the last thing we haven't talked
about is story well this is supposed to
take place between Revenge of the Sith
and you hope you know which we've seen a
lot of at this point actually I wrote
one actually I wrote one the rebels
cartoon there's a lot of books now that
I've kind of been filling in that gap
where do you feel like this story I
guess what is it going to provide that
that is gonna be newer interesting do
you think yeah in a Star Wars story you
know that that sort of gap between the
different trilogy is still very much a
great gray area within Star Wars lore
like even though we have like you know
TV series and a film like uh you know
there's still a lot you can sort of do
with it kind of what the Canon
yeah basically and what's interesting is
that uh this story you know speaking of
the form previous Canon you know the
story actually has familiar echoes to
like sort of the previous like a Jedi
Knight series like from the 90s right
with a Kyle Katarn who is a non-existent
yeah you're very much a Jedi you know a
new Jedi in training and you know
gradually sort of building power and
like coming into your own and along the
way your course gonna run into familiar
characters and maybe familiar like you
know sort of locations that you know
like like for instance sauger era from
Rogel one actually shows up in the
rights voiced by force whitaker as well
okay wow that's on the planet Kashyyyk
so you're actually gonna be you know
rubbing shoulders with rookies and you
know just getting to fight with uh
against the empire
you know i remember than showing off
some of that at e3 yeah actually like
callow a lot more than expected
i was a little worried that he seemed
maybe a bit too familiar as I guess a
Star Wars protagonist Yeah right
especially considering like you know the
previous in like games like Jedi Knight
or four so Force Unleashed have you know
a very similar style of like you know
sort of new Jedi with powers that is
definitely something I've always felt is
that a Star Wars can get locked in
together and character protagonists
archetype
so how did was he different I guess he
was a lot more curious you know he was
also he also had a great set of a
supporting characters around him with
them you actually have a ship and on the
ship you'll have your your crew like
Assyria and Brees I actually got some
bit of sort of Mass Effect vibes like
just being able to explore the ship and
like you know oh right Republic yeah
okay I like that a lot that's cool
actually that would have been better to
say nice too Knights are their world but
no I mean like it's a it was it was
really interesting just soaring sort of
getting to know those characters and you
know I really appreciate just how much
how much lore is actually in the game
because uh when you're exploring like of
course like you know with ties to
Metroidvania and particularly Metroid
Prime you can actually scan different
aspects of the environment and fallen
enemies and you'll actually get sort of
lower details about them and you know
it's interesting just sort of like
having more information just sort of
like gradually fed to you right yeah I
mean from what you've described I
definitely am more interested in this
game now because I think I was a little
worried it was gonna be just sort of
more a very linear compact game you know
which the combat sounds like it's pretty
good but I was hoping there'd be a
little more but it sounds like you have
the characters in your ship you can
County which I wasn't expecting
Metroidvania stuff the multiple plants
you can kind of pick the game is a lot
more open than I expected right it's a
lot more dense than I then I expected
cuz I was with right there with you like
I was thinking it's gonna be very linear
you go here you know go there like very
much like in the vein of previous like
Star Wars games single-player Star Wars
games so yeah I was very impressed that
you know just just the scope of it and
you know of course we only saw just one
like I only played through like the to
completion one planet and that took over
two hours and there's still a set of
other planets like Kashyyyk and darth
amir and uh you know and of course
there's all there's another set of plans
to be revealed later on was you go
through the story as well as oh cool
alright well that was your three hour
impressions with Jedi fallen order now
the full game comes out November 15th so
we got about a month to look forward to
the final product and we can see how the
full game shapes up yeah it's the first
real as I said is the first real Star
Wars Metroidvania game or
I guess you want to be cheeky about it
like a Jedi Vania I guess so maybe it's
a lot more dense and you know exciting
than I expected and I'm really looking
forward to checking out more yeah I'm
definitely curious as somebody who grew
up playing a lot of Star Wars games and
then there's that kind of golden age
where there there's just a lot of
variety and you know different genres
and I feel like ever since Star Wars has
kind of come back there really hasn't
been that many so it's nice to finally
start seeing a couple of new new Star
Wars games that are going in a different
direction so we'll see how the full game
shapes up when it comes out and for all
future Jedi fall in order coverage stay
tuned the game spot
[Music]
by right Thank You Evan
Thank You Evan